Stephanie is in Green Bay Wisconsin
hi Stephanie how are you hi good how are
you better than I deserve what's up so
my husband and I are considering
building a second home by our parents
wonderful we'd like your conservative
opinion awesome they're having a hard
time pulling the trigger on it you know
pay tax we are we are 31 years old and
our projected income for 8 2018 is 1.7
to two million dollars good more it's my
husband's in real estate and I'm a
genetics provider look at you two why
did it go thank you thank you we worked
hard we worked really hard yeah you have
yeah I know the house well so there's
one there's one faster our only that is
we have a 1.1 million dollars in a
commercial building that's projected to
be paid off by the end of 2018 our
dinners so it's actually supposed to be
paid off by November if everything works
out okay oh we own our home all right as
well as three and a half million dollars
in commercial real estate all right you
guys are amazing
well done how much money did you inherit
yeah just your fabulous income that did
this we didn't inherit any what's your
30 years old
yeah gosh my husband's very animal yeah
we would lean in meet my parents did
have a college account for me that they
said if you have any money left when
you're done with school it's yours the
key okay I didn't understand you have an
annual income of 1.7 million yeah
holy moly okay so I'm so proud of y'all
well done thank you so how much is this
house cost well we want to do it as
cheaply you think as we can as my
husband thinks he can manage a project
and we can do it for about 500,000 okay
then your how to pay cash right so with
with the monthly payment for my real
estate from our commercial real estate
and then we're gonna pay also the
commercial real estate a little bit
slower but cause you did this house no
we're not gonna do the house until this
commercial properties paid off oh and
then you're gonna pay cash for the house
yep oh this is kind of a no-brainer why
would you not do it well
we've lived so lean and mean for so long
it's it's hard to it's hard to pull the
trigger on something like this okay let
me tell you that there's a balance here
okay there there is great wisdom coming
from a 30 something year old making this
kind of money to say I'm gonna live lean
and mean and I want you to continue to
do that I don't want you to act like you
hit the lotto or you're some kind of you
know drunk rock star or something right
or you are where you lose all your money
we don't want you to be that guy you're
not heading that way so let's live lean
and mean but there's three things you
can do with money of this size matter of
fact there's three things you can do if
you have two dollars and you ought to do
all three at all times you ought to be
giving you ought to be investing and you
ought to be enjoying you have been great
at investing I suspect you've been doing
a lot of giving I kind to hear that but
I just heard it between the lines I
didn't actually hear statements we
hadn't talked about that yet but where
you're struggling on those three it's
harder for you to enjoy it because
you're afraid you're going to become
that guy right the one who made a lot of
money and was stupid you don't be that
guy right right right that's what I'm
worried about
yeah where this is open shot here's how
here's how you know you're not that guy
anyway you want and then you can make
all these decisions later easily it's
all about ratios most people don't have
a $500,000 second home that they paid
for in cash but most people don't have a
1.7 million our income at 31 years old
so most people are not our measure as to
whether this is wise what whether what
our measure is ratios as a percentage of
your net worth as a percentage of your
income what are you spending on toys
lifestyle and second houses and cars and
boats are toys and lifestyle I have two
second houses a second and a third house
okay I have two boats two sea-doos a
bunch of cars okay
but they if you add all of that together
it is less than 5% of my net worth so if
it all burns down tomorrow my life
didn't change you follow me mm-hmm
that's how you I know I'm not out of
control my giving is much larger than my
consuming my investing is much larger
than my consuming even though my level
of consumption versus most people or
versus the way I grew up I'm a kid from
Antioch Tennessee the life I get to lead
today blows my mind
you know but it's an unusual life I'm in
an unusual place and so that's just the
way it is
so if I buy a brand new Corvette which
is sitting out front I it doesn't effect
I mean it's mathematically like when I
used to buy a biscuit you know you
follow me
yeah and that tells me I'm not being
spiritually out of control I'm not
worshiping stuff because the percentage
is such a small percentage of my life
now other people see it and they've all
got a lot of things to say about what
you do but other people aren't running
your life and other people weren't given
1.7 million dollar income by God for
them to manage they've just given to you
so you keep your ratios in check and
take all your toys and put them in a
pile and say if we lost them all
tomorrow would it mess up our life
severely financially not emotionally
emotionally be a problem right but
severely my lake house boats houses cars
all my way tomorrow I would even blink
financially and you wouldn't either
would you no okay I mean you could lose
your house you could lose this five
hundred thousand dollar house you could
lose all your cars and whatever other
toys you've got sitting around and with
your income and your net worth
already you told me about three and a
half million dollars in in commercial
real estate and 1.7 million our income
it wouldn't matter so your ratios are in
check and that says that you're not that
guy that guy is the guy makes a million
seven and spend seventeen million with
his posse that's that guy
or gives his mama an 8 million dollar
house it makes a million in half here
that's that guy you're not gonna be that
guy that's where the ratios went the
other way out of whack over the top so
you're doing great hold on imma send you
a copy of our latest book called the
legacy journey it's the only book I've
ever written about wealth all the other
books I wrote were about money and it
talks a lot about the stuff we just
talked about here even the spiritual
implications of it this is the Dave
Ramsey shop